c'est une petite révolution qui secoue
l'eau ville pour s'affranchir des
embouteillages autant que de la
pollution
rien de tel que de renouer avec notre
bon vieux vélos et les chiffres sont
formels à tour 7 % de la population
utilise désormais pour ses déplacements
quotidiens en délaissant la politique du
tout voiture comment les villes s'adapte
t elle aujourd'hui pour offrir au vélo
toute sa place comment concilier ou
plutôt réconcilier les différents modes
de transport exemple avec la métropole
tourangelle ou ruse et usages sont en
pleine mutation pour se frayer un chemin
cette sacrée petite reine est prête à
tout elle s'est même invitée dans la
toute récente campagne des élections
municipales
au point de devenir pour les candidats
un véritable enjeu politique
tours est la première ville en france la
première au nombre de deux
km de pistes cyclables par habitant donc
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya une attention
qui n'est pas d'aujourd'hui et
inattention qu'elle continue sur le vélo
le tout vélo non le vélo protéger oui au
maximum dans la ville oui mais pas
contre déjà d'activité commerciale qui
peut y avoir un centre-ville faut
absolument l'encourager puisqu'il ya en
plus une demande sociétale forte et en
plus on se rend compte particulièrement
en prenant l'exemple de tours que c'est
une alternative très crédible très forte
à à la voiture nous ce qu'on veut faire
c'est un vrai réseau de rêve des réseaux
express vélos qui sont des est ce qu'on
appelle les autoroutes à vélo qui sont
dédiés au vélo sécurisé donc qui
permettent également d'avoir un bon
service c'est-à-dire d'aller d'un point
a à un point b
rapidement c'est que le vélo est
redevenu un objet de rêve capable de
séduire les plus réfractaires
[Musique]
c'est un vélo rallonger qui permet de
transporter des enfants et des charges
ici vous avez un vélo booster qui permet
de transporter des handicapés accidentés
ou personnages et même rallongé pousseur
à assistance électrique vélomobile pour
aller très très vite by porter
triporteur cargo les modèles proposés
aujourd'hui n'ont plus rien à voir avec
la bicyclette d'entendre il ya aussi les
utilitaires en plein renouveau il ya des
des besoins qui auquel les vélos peuvent
répondre transport de charges transport
de personnes et là on est réellement
maintenant dans le vélo alternative à la
voiture
proposer une véritable alternative à la
voilà l'enjeu ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à faire ce choix pour leur vie
de tous les jours comme pour leurs
déplacements professionnels
allez c'est parti pour soutenir la
journée commence à vélo direction la
maison de la nounou à quelques
kilomètres où elle dépose ses deux
enfants
retour à la maison et son vélo cargo se
transforme en outil professionnel j'ai
fait le choix de pas avoir de voiture et
après dans mon boulot mais comme je suis
confuse itinérante ça me permet de me
déplacer d'un rendez-vous à l'autre avec
tout le nécessaire dans la caisse de mon
vélo
en fait je faisais pas du tout vélo
avant de lancer dans mon activité que
mon vélo carbo je me suis mise pour tous
les autres arguments que vraiment le
fait de faire du vélo
et finalement c'est vraiment pas
compliqué et maintenant c'est un vrai
plaisir au quotidien me déplacer d'un
rendez-vous à l'autre c'est hyper
hyper pratique c'est rapide je me me
stationner très facilement et à côté de
ça c'était vraiment en accord avec ma
façon de travailler avec mes convictions
mathieu et jardiner premier défi pour me
charger son véhicule
le broyeur je mets tout en lavant les
échelles je l'aimé tout le temps sur la
caisse à droite les objets très long sur
l'échelle à droite
maintenant je sais le début on se
demande comment on va faire pour pour
tout emmené il ya un côté convivial
boutons sur place en ville à vélo on
n'est pas protégé par une carrosserie on
peut dire bonjour et moins de moins de
pression et plus ouvert sur le monde
chargé l'ange à est impressionnant il
peut cependant se révéler comme un
précieux allié dans ce type de jardin
c'est un atout parce que j'amène tout
mon matériel directement dans le jardin
alors que le garage était tout petit
donc j'aurais pas pu le faire avec un
camion benne traditionnel donc là je
vais
être très avantagé pour tout ce qui est
à moins de 10 kilomètres à la ronde de
chez moi c'est super
il ya peut-être certains matins je me
dis mais
la carriole que tu as fabriqué là on
dirait un jouet est ce que c'est pas un
petit peu enfantin de faire ça et d'un
autre côté il ya des articles aussi très
sérieux qui montrent l'urgence de
changer de société parce que je fais
c'est important même si c'est à petite
échelle servir d'exemple et montrer que
c'est possible pour espérer développer
l'usagé du vélo dans une métropole
il faut bichonner ses adeptes a fortiori
s'ils sont aussi touristes nous entrons
dans la maison du vélo
ici on peut réparer sa monture se
restaurer ou prendre une douche
c'est l'une des toutes premières avoir
été créé en france mais très rapidement
cette capitainerie du cycliste a réservé
une surprise
cette installation qui était faite au
début réellement pour exclusivement
j'allais dire les touristes pour les
conserver un petit peu la tour
progressivement les tourangeaux se la
sont appropriée des cyclistes tourangeau
toujours plus nombreux et des pouvoirs
publics qui finissent par s'engager dans
une réelle politique d'aménagement en
est en plein développement depuis
maintenant je dirais deux trois ans on a
changé de braquet
on a plus de 600 km sur la métropole
équipés pour le vélo dont environ 80km
de vraies pistes 75 kg mais de bandes
cyclables des shows si doux etc et des
voix apaisée plus vous offrez de
services plus vous offrez de piste plus
vos sauts frais de stationnement plus
les gens iront sur le vélo
problème le ressenti des cyclistes n'est
pas toujours au rendez-vous et l'afub la
puissante fédération des usagers de la
bicyclette livre de bien mauvais
résultats dans son dernier baromètre
voilà c'est que liz may geneva est rose
à se déporter problèmes de stationnement
sur les pistes cyclables manque d'effort
de la ville le constat est sévère
est-ce qui fait david alias davidoff est
un authentique militant de la cause du
vélo sans relâche il parcourt les rues
de la ville
trac et dénonce la moindre embûche
[Musique]
les nids de poule c'est pas ça pas l'air
très graves comme ça mais soit on peut
chuter dans parce qu'on prend l'air ou
dedans mais on peut aussi crevé la rue
michelet c'est pâques aussi maria
toujours toujours des voitures qui
stationnent parce que c'est un rôle
citoyen remontée des difficultés ça me
paraît normal
david est aussi un membre très actif du
collectif cycliste 37 un collectif qui
compte aujourd'hui plus de mille
adhérents une sacrée force de
proposition aussi qui a entrepris un
travail de lobbying auprès des élus
locaux tour notre problème c'est que on
a énormément de trottoirs partager ou
finalement on est obligés de circuler
avec les piétons et et surtout sur les
axes où il ya un fort trafic motorisé il
ya beaucoup de voitures et aussi où
elles vont vite on a vraiment ce besoin
d'être séparé de cette circulation pour
se sentir en sécurité
ce que le collectif cycliste défense et
notamment l'idée d'un réseau express
vélo avec ses itinéraires totalement
dédiée ce et des aménagements dans des
rues existantes en site propre c'est à
dire que les cyclistes vont être isolés
de la circulation automobile et de la
circulation des piétons
donc ça va leur permettre d'avoir une
vitesse constante et donc d'avoir des
temps de parcours relativement court
puisque joué-lès-tours gare de tours ça
se fait quasiment en 20 25 minutes
voyez pour changer effectivement il faut
donner du confort et de la sécurité aux
cyclistes donc ça va réduire la voiture
en plus c'est idéal qu'on prévoit ils
sont pris en partie sur l'itinéraire
automobile un peu pour l'instant donc ça
va forcément rayonne flux parce qu'on
sait bien que moi il ya des espaces pour
les voitures et pour se garer et pour
rouler et moi yara de véhicules
repenser la circulation et sa hiérarchie
pour établir ces nouveaux itinéraires il
convient au préalable de les tester
allez on démarre on est parti une
mission du jour pour ce petit groupe de
cyclistes chronométrés leur temps de
parcours en pleine heure de pointe
attention top 9057 9057 et 79 secondes
[Rires]
sur quoi sert c'est là où les voitures
sont à touche touche en attendant que le
feu passe au vert on double facilement
les voitures que les gens ne se rendent
pas compte du temps qu'il met pour aller
d'un point à un autre entre le temps
d'aller chercher sa voiture la voile est
stationné de faire le trajet de trouver
une place de stationnement et de revenir
à l'endroit précis où on veut vraiment
aller
havel on y est déjà de fait pas mal de
temps tous les trajets de moins de 5 km
sont en réalité beaucoup plus rapide et
bicyclettes c'est la revanche du vélo
sur sa rivale à quatre roues restent un
frein à son développement et pas des
moindres acquérir et entretenir sa
monture coûte cher dans ce grand atelier
du collectif peut tout apprendre à
réparer soi-même son vélo dati vient sur
le pneu oui et après deux tirs sur laval
pour commencer les tringles au moins ça
nous aide beaucoup
ah bah oui quand tu viens entre eux soit
nous bon accueil voilà quand tu
adhérents ça nous fait du bien ça nous
facilite la tâche
et puis dans cet atelier on joue aussi
la carte de l'économie circulaire les
yeux vélos sont démontés recyclés et
remis en circulation
ici rien ne se perd c'est fou libre elle
va finir dans le stock de pièces qu'on
essaie près l'ensemble des pièces parce
que savard servir donc celle ci elle va
être là dans cette boîte ça découle une
à trois voire quatre vitesses
c'est notre économie mais on peut
tellement sauver de choses qui vont me
permet de produire parce qu'elles
existent déjà et à une époque y avait
des pièces de plutôt bonne qualité qui
trente quarante ans après ou encore une
excellente tenue donc a pas de problème
et leur utiliser à loisir
j'essaie de trouver les pièces les moins
abîmée pour avoir des vélos en état
correct et pour pouvoir les proposer un
prix pas trop élevé
ce vélo il sera très bien pour un enfant
et il sera correct au niveau esthétique
parce que j'aime bien aussi que ça soit
beau j'aime bien que c'est pas parce que
c'est un vélo d'occasion de cette vente
mais acquérir un vélo bon marché c'est
bien mais s'en servir en toute sécurité
n'est pas toujours si simple à prendre
l'equilibre adopter les bons réflexes
dans cette vélo école créée il ya une
douzaine d'années on met en selle des
débutants de tous âges
débarquer les premiers tours de roues
sont un peu hésitants sous l'oeil
bienveillant de son moniteur pauline
prend peu à peu confiance
je n'ai pas aussi de voiture je n'ai pas
de ressources c'est un moyen de
déplacement pour moi ce qui est avec la
voiture il faut beaucoup dépensé il faut
de carburant alors qu'avec le vélo je
peux me déplacer aller n'importe où avec
tous les deux cette école du vélo elle a
vraiment pour objectif de donner de
l'autonomie c'est donner aux gens
l'opportunité d'utiliser le vélo comme
mode de déplacement au quotidien ça peut
être aussi bien pour du loisir que pour
des déplacements dit utilitaire donc
aller travailler à vélo faire un stage
suivre une formation
comme je dis souvent on est un peu
l'école de la dernière chance on a
beaucoup d'élèves nous qui arrive aux
cliniciens de débutants absolue qui
n'ont pas les équilibres sur le vélo et
qu'ils ont peut être essayer d'apprendre
à faire du vélo seul ou en famille ou
entre amis elles sont pas forcément
réussi et donc nous on est on est là
pour leur donner pour leur donner une
chance supplémentaire
[Musique]
redonnez l'envi après des décennies du
tout-voiture offrir enfin toutes leurs
chances aux mobilités douces
voilà l'enjeu des prochaines années un
bon moyen pour rendre la vie plus sûre
et plus apaisé
[Musique]